in this video i'm going to tell you who
to hire first when you are scaling your
business
number one question i get all the time
is when should i hire who do i hire at
what point do i know it's right and the
first secret to this is that you're
never going to know by the way my name
is alex ramozzi on acquisition.com we're
going to portfolio companies of 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you all right so let's rock and
roll so one of the biggest issues is
when you're starting as a business owner
is that you don't know what the hell
you're doing right and that's okay
but what i want to introduce you is a
simple concept that i use um when
thinking through this as a simple tool
that you can use when you think about
your stack of time all right so let's
say that this is all of the time that
you have in your day let's say you spend
a certain amount of time doing uh you
know admin work
and then you do some sales
and you do some marketing
and you do some uh you know let's say
billing
and then you do some uh you know
customer facing stuff the way that you
determine
which of these things you hire next is
you look at two factors number one
is what is the greatest percentage of
your time like where's the greatest
percentage of your time that you were
spending number two is what is the cost
that's the lowest cost activity that is
the highest percentage of time and so
what you want to look at here is a
scribe of value to each of these types
of things now you can look at market
value or what i prefer to do is which of
these things is making me the most money
all right so
right now there will probably be
activities in your business that make
you money but they don't make you as
much money as let's say sales does and
so we're not going to outsource
something that's crucial to the business
at this early stage when we have
something let's say admin and billing
that we can outsource earlier on that
have a lower likelihood of impacting
your business in a negative way all
right so we're really trying to play
defense here when we're looking at how
we're going to hire and the objective
and this is the main thing here because
understanding what problem we are
solving is one of the most important
aspects of entrepreneurship is picking
the problem that we're truly solving
most people start solving problems that
don't even exist we're solving problems
that not aren't even problems in their
business they're not even constraints
that exist and so the objective of the
hire should be to give you time it
should be to give you time back
and so the idea is how can i get the
most time back for the least amount of
money and that's consistently the
process that you'll continue to do in
your entrepreneurial journey is how do i
get more time back over and over and
over again and independent what everyone
says the process of entrepreneurship is
just buying back time and increasing
your level of skill so that you can do
higher and higher revenue activities to
the point where the only thing and i'll
tell you whether the final place that
you'll have is that you'll just be
making decisions
right this is the highest level and then
beyond that it's having a vision that
everyone is aligned with that they're
making their decisions
through you provide the lens through
which people
underneath of you make decisions in
alignment so that they can move the
entire organization forward on your
behalf now
when you're starting out
most times
most times what you will need to end up
doing your first one of your first two
hires will be one of these two things
a it will be some sort of administrative
help or some sort of first follower who
will help you who believes in you
believes in your vision and like this is
why spouses a lot of times end up being
that first hire right that girlfriend or
whatever who ends up believing in you
and you know quitting their job so that
they can you know support you and you
guys go do this thing together right and
that's because they're gonna be they're
gonna be more invested you get way more
work out of that person than you would
out of a normal employee but you can
also find those types of people and that
is very common as the first type of hire
is kind of a
a jack of all trades admin help person
all right the other type of hire that i
see so there's usually one of these two
is the first hire
is somebody who can assist with the
fulfillment so if you have productized
your service which is going to be one of
the first things you need to do is
figure out how you can rep reliably
replicate the same outcome among
customers which is why it's important to
narrow down the type of customer you're
servicing and the type of outcome you're
delivering so that you can make it
easier for someone else to accomplish
the same thing as you so that you can
focus on running the business and not
actually doing the thing you are selling
it is productizing the service and so
that means that
in the beginning you'll need to always
work overtime because you're basically
working one and a half or double so
you're working on doing the business
things while also building the
infrastructure foundation so that other
people can work within this model most
people who are starting out i'll write
this down for you so that you can have a
visual for it number one is usually
either an admin slash helper
for you or
company somebody to help with customer
fulfillment those are typically one of
the first two hires you will have and
this is obviously with a broad
generalization based on a founder owned
bootstrap business that doesn't have
funding which 99 of businesses fall in
that category all right now if you're a
three founder you know vc backed startup
then obviously you might have different
hiring schema right off the bat but if
you're starting this from your from
ground zero and this is you and you are
hustling these are usually going to be
the first two uh highers you have
because these are usually the things
that take you the most amount of time
that provide the least amount of value
all right so that you continue to work
your way up this uh this this this value
ladder which i can probably do at
another time as you go up this this
ladder they should be the things that
take you uh that bring the most amount
of money and the least amount of time so
this is a little time hourglass which i
failed miserably at but the most amount
of money least amount of time that is
what you're you're spending your time
doing and you outsource
these things
in this order
and that is the thought process that i
use when i'm trying to figure out what
things and what people i need to hire
next which is what's taking me the most
amount of time that i can buy from the
marketplace the least amount of money
emoji nation make these videos because a
lot of people are broken on would you be
one of them i want you to scale the crap
out of your business and i'd love to
know um that this video helped you so
anyways lots of love keeping awesome
nothing to sell you and i'll see you
guys the next vid bye